Mawson: Hi, I'm Sven Mawson
and I'll be speaking
at Google I/O this year.
I'll be discussing the evolution
of the Google data protocol
and some new features
we're introducing
to make it easier to build
efficient applications.
The Google data APIs
are a great way to get data
into and out of Google
applications,
but they aren't very efficient
at the protocol level.
This makes them less useful
than we'd like them to be
for latency-sensitive tasks,
such as driving an AJAX UI.
So we're introducing
some new ways to reduce
both the bandwidth
and the latency
when communicating
with Google services
through the data protocol.
And we're making
the programming model
easier while we're at it.
One of the new features
we're introducing
is a new JSON format
that is smaller, faster,
and simpler to use
than the existing format.
This new format uses
many fewer JavaScript objects
and much less room on the wire
to significantly reduce
the amount of bandwidth
and latency used
by the protocol.
As we see in this example,
in a feed of 500 photos
from the Picasa web albums API,
the existing JSON format
takes 770 kilobytes of space.
Using the new JSON format,
these feed only takes
385 kilobytes of space.
And using the new JSON format
plus partial gets,
another feature we'll be
introducing
at Google I/O this year,
it only takes 70 kilobytes
of space.
That's just 1/10 the size
of the original feed.
So I hope to see you
at Google I/O in San Francisco
and I look forward
to seeing you there.